hey youtubers it's Charlie so because of
all the arrow flash spin-off news I
wanted to do a dedicated video for the
top five stories I think they should
adapt and I'll also try to explain what
kind of show I think it's gonna be they
haven't said what the name is gonna be
like what the title they're gonna call
it is it could be all stars it could be
the atom because it's gonna be an
ensemble team-up show I think that
they're gonna pick from one of the DC
teams obviously they're not gonna let
them use the name Justice League but
there's always just a society there's
always All Stars any variation on that
infinity Inc just think of all the teams
that do not use the words Justice League
I still think that the atom is gonna be
the quarterback of the team and because
there's still a lot of questions as to
how it's gonna use firestorm I can't
really say a whole lot about that Martin
Stein's gonna be on the show that's all
we know we don't know if Robbie Amell is
gonna be on it just add a little context
if you don't know about the history of
this spin-off show originally it was
just supposed to be for the atom it was
gonna be like his own show but I think
they saw the firestorm episodes and
everyone responded so well to that
character that the CW was like please
give us more firestorm and this is the
easiest way for them to do it without
crowding team flash that's one of the
bad parts about having so many awesome
guests actors on arrow in the flash is
that a lot of those actors can carry
their own shows but there's no room for
him right now so that's what this new
show is for that's why Captain Cold
arguably a rogue that should stay on the
flash is going on the team-up show just
because as an actor Wentworth Miller is
so good he needs more screen time but
you can only use Captain Cold so much on
the flash given the characters that they
have right now I'm choosing to think of
this more as like a full-blown science
bros show like flare Oh science bros so
considering that here the top 5 comic
book storylines I think they should
adapt starting off with number 5 Justice
Society justice be done this was the
first new JSA story of the modern age it
was all about them putting the team back
together
it featured black Canary atom smasher
the Jay Garrick flash Wildcat Wonder
Woman Power Man in a couple of the
lesser characters they all come together
to help the new dr. fate fight more - as
you can see they'd have to change some
aspects of this get rid of the magical
elements and make it more of an x-files
CSI tech based adventure show like
solving paranormal metahuman mysteries
using Palmer tech and Martin Stein
science regardless of which story they
choose to adapt I mean the tone of the
show is going to flow from the
characters that they have firestorm and
Adam
total science bros Constantine and the
new Lucifer show that Fox is doing those
are like the magic shows so all the
magic stuff is probably to be localized
to that of course I say that you know
and they'll probably announce some magic
based character for the flash season - I
feel like that show has almost no limits
moving on to number four though
brightest day so this is a story where
Ronnie Raymond came back from the dead
in the firestorm matrix starts acting
all weird
brawny goes back to Pittsburgh
University to try and put his life back
together gets into a fight with Jason
Rush and when Jason punches him they
fuse into firestorm with Ronnie and
control it's just that earlier in the
comics during the Infinite Crisis
storyline Ronnie Raymond died Jason rush
took the mantle and became the firestorm
in the comics so Ronnie Raymond comes
back and they have to figure out who's
gonna be firestorm and what's gonna look
like so you get Martin Stein off by
himself just being Martin Stein in human
form super-smart scientist and then you
have two young characters flying around
in firestorm things got really timey
wimey after that with the death storm
like the Black Lantern firestorm I don't
think they're gonna do any of that kind
of stuff but I do think that they're
gonna change who gets to be inside the
firestorm matrix I think that that would
go a long way towards explaining how
Martin Stein can be on this spin-off
show without Robbie Amell being on it
and them being firestorm together so if
Robbie Amell is gonna continue to be
firestorm and not be on the spin-off
show that means that they're gonna have
to find a way to bring Jason Rusch into
the equation moving on to number three
the firestorm protocols so this is a new
52 story line where Ronnie Raymond -
Jason rush have to deal with a bunch of
rogue fire storms that have been created
when other people get their hands on
Martin Stein's firestorm protocols that
it's basically blueprints for creating
more fire storms they kind of tease this
in the flash episode 14 when general
Eiling said the military scientists
found a way to extract the firestorm
matrix from Martin Stein's body if they
did that they'd be able to replicate an
army of fire storms that was what
general Eiling was trying to do so that
plot lines always gonna be a threat
there'll always be people trying to
steal the secret of firestorm moving on
to number two the fury of firestorm this
was the very first story that they told
in the new 52 firestorm comics like
right after flashpoint in this
continuity Martin Stein is dead but he's
given his research to Jason Rush and
both Jason and Ronnie Raymond are able
to become firestorm on their own so you
have two different
firestorms at once martin stein bequeath
something called the god particle to
jason rusch it's just research of his
based on the firestorm matrix it causes
both fire storms to fuse together into
this like mega a combiner firestorm
called the fury it's like the next
evolution of fire storms power so it's
it's really interesting
hopefully they'll deal with that on the
show they've been doing a lot of super
powers on the flash i think that they'll
go full steam ahead on this spinoff show
too there was also a time as part of an
earlier storyline when the atom actually
shrinks down to go inside the firestorm
matrix and walk around and see what's
happening so there have actually been a
lot of crossovers between atom and
firestorm stories so I imagine that was
also a big discussion point when they
were deciding what kind of team up show
this was gonna be you get the general
gist though you have the atom
billionaire just like Oliver Queen
funding this team of superheroes with
this wise scientist Martin Stein helping
them out hopefully we'll get like an
x-files adventure show vibe I'm really
hoping for like x-files in the DC
universe and this one is a total long
shot but my number one pick would be the
birth of the Red Tornado remember how I
said I'm expecting full-blown science
Bros well what's the next logical step
in that that they haven't done in the TV
DC universe yet artificial intelligence
right now there's a very popular movie
that's coming out soon that's dealing
with that idea
and for those that haven't read the
comics yes Red Tornado total analog of
the vision from Avengers evil villain
creates an Android to infiltrate
superhero team and take them down in the
DC Universe T omorrow is the scientist
that creates Red Tornado to take down
the Justice League the really cool thing
is is that he used to work at STAR Labs
because STAR Labs is such a big thing on
the flash already you just you already
have this big point of crossover to tell
this huge story so the birth of the Red
Tornado is just a point of crossover for
all of the CW shows I mean you get you
get I in like the Supergirl show too but
I'm not expecting as much crossover with
that as I am with shows that are on the
same network here's my big question for
you guys which storyline do you want to
see them adapt for this new spin-off
show just remember if arrow can do
Batman stories then you can pick from
Justice League any comic book story you
want there are a couple characters that
I really like to see them try and do
like Booster Gold Red Tornado obviously
at some point I'm not expecting Green
Lantern I feel like he might be
introduced in the movies first before we
see him on TV I know there are lots of
Green Lantern's they could do but I've
feel like DC would be really reticent to
let him appear on TV if they have a big
movie planned for him just because so
many of these shows are on different
networks there are a lot of questions
about who gets to use which side
characters so hopefully by the time we
get to comic-con all the networks will
have announced who they've cast which
characters are using so we'll have a
better idea of what its gonna look like
here's actually here's a roundup of all
the different shows and the different
networks so on the CW we have arrow the
flash a vixen digital cartoon that's not
gonna be on TV that'll be on the web and
then now the atom firestorm spin-off at
Fox there's Gotham that's coming back
for season two then there's the Lucifer
show that's actually part of Neil
Gaiman's Sandman universe CBS has
Supergirl TNT has the live-action Teen
Titans show and NBC hasn't said anything
about constantine yet so we'll just put
a big question mark there but those are
all the TV shows I know I haven't done a
lot of Supergirl videos yet but I will
start doing some soon while I was making
this video they actually announced Dean
Cain and Helen Slater are being cast for
the pilot that's a pretty big WTF they
they didn't say who they're playing they
just had they been cast in the pilot so
no idea if they'll return and recurring
roles like they'll be on the show every
week it could be like a John Wesley
Shipp thing where they play Kara's
Kryptonian parents here's a really
interesting thing that we need to think
about because supergirls origin is tied
to the bottled city of Kandor I'm really
interested to see if the show is gonna
go there or if they're just gonna bypass
it all together there's no way we're
gonna make it through comic-con without
people asking them those questions so
hopefully we'll learn more pretty soon
the show itself is gonna be procedural
because it's on CBS so no idea like how
many they're gonna get with comic book
storylines for those that are asking yes
I am gonna be doing weekly videos for
the show whenever it comes so be sure to
subscribe to get all that stuff I'll
start doing bonus videos pretty soon - I
have no idea what the fall schedule is
gonna be hopefully it all works out and
all the shows don't air on the same day
that'd be a nightmare for me because
it's Friday and I've already done a
whole bunch of DC videos I think my next
videos going to be the Black Panther
video that I keep putting off so while
you guys wait for that you can click
here to catch up on the flash and you
can click here to catch up on arrow
thank you so much for watching so let's
all high-five
everybody live long and prosper may you
rest in peace Leonard Nimoy
you